hey guys
last time we learned that although most
classical guitarists today
play the guitar with nails on their
plucking hand
that wasn't always the case and so i cut
off my nails
there's still no nail in fact i even now
even don't have a thumbnail
and so i'm really committed to the whole
idea of playing with flesh and that's
been really interesting but today we're
going to go a bit deeper
and we're going to put on historical
strings and that means
gut strings so i have ordered them
my gut strings have arrived uh we're
going to put these on
and then we're going to do some sound
comparisons with synthetic strings
and gut strings and we're gonna see
which sounds better
so here is playing the guitar with gut
strings
so for most of history gut strings were
the most common type of string used
by classical guitarists violinists
violists
and many more instrumentalists they were
made from the dried intestines of
animals like sheep and originally
on guitars they were used for the
strings and the frets
so for baroque guitars and loots even
they didn't have metal frets they would
tie the
the same materials strings the gut
around
and that's how they got fronts the metal
fretting didn't come around
until the early 19th century actually
but you know my main reason for making
this video is that
which string material you use has a huge
impact
on how your instrument sounds you can
make a really good instrument
sound terrible with bad strings and
since most classical guitarists for most
of history used
gut strings and that's all my favorite
composers you know
sore targa merits giuliani
all of them thought of the guitar heard
the guitar with gut strings
and so i thought i really want to know
what that sounds like
so let's find out bear with me here as i
change the strings
[Music]
alright we are all strung up with gust
strings
this is super exciting i have made some
recordings before changing the strings
with the strings that were already on
here those were synthetic strings made
by a company called aquila
they were nile gut which is basically a
synthetic version
of guts let's hear those plucked open
followed by the real deal the gut
[Music]
strings
all right now we'll dive into some
pieces this is francisco tarraga's
capriccio arabe
[Music]
so
[Music]
so i have to say that right away i'm
like already so impressed
with the gut strings i've never heard
this instrument
sound so good um this is a torres
replica by sayer's guitars
which is a a torrez is a guitar that
that francisco targa himself
would have been familiar with and would
have owned one and man this instrument
has never sounded this good
so let's hear another piece by targa uh
let's try
adelita
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
one of the things i'm noticing is that
the gut strings have a texture
to them they have some friction so that
means that i can really grab the string
and feel like i'm
caressing the sound out of it in
comparison the
synthetic strings are super slippery and
it's harder to get a grip on it i think
also i'm having the same realization i
did when i changed my theorbo to gut
strings which is that
the synthetic strings in comparison to
these sound a bit plasticky and a bit
thin whereas the gut strings just have
this resonance
this warmth to it
which i i'm just totally loving since
i've never felt that
on classical guitar and the combination
of flesh and gut strings
uh is just really really nice but let's
hear another sound comparison
uh this is a piece by the spanish
composer fernando soare
who was a no nails player and definitely
would have been playing on gut strings
this is his variations on a theme by
mozart
this is one of the later variations
[Music]
when i first put the gut strings on and
tried to play that
i was blown away it's so much easier
with gut strings maybe it's the string
tension
maybe it's the fact that i can there's a
bit of grip on the string because the
friction but like
[Music]
i found it so easy the second i had the
gut strings on
all right we're just gonna do one more
sound comparison and this one was
particularly interesting because
one of my concerns about putting gut
strings on a classical guitar
was i thought i was going to lose a lot
of sustain sustain is just you know the
length
of a note how long does it ring right
and when i put gut strings on my fiorbo
i found especially in the bases
uh the sound really kind of cut off
a lot faster than with synthetic strings
and actually with a theorbo that works
in its favor
because you don't want the notes to over
ring however on a classical guitar
you do want sustain so i thought a good
revealing piece
to hear the difference between synthetic
and gut strings
would be the prelude to la catidral
by barrios
[Music]
so
[Music]
and to my surprise the gut strings
don't sound like they have less sustain
to me and in fact the tone color is
really
beautiful up top and i much prefer it to
the synthetic strings
so i really have to say that i think i
am a gut string convert through and
through
at first i thought it was just for my
early plucked instruments but
man like the resonance the clarity
the grip on the strings i'm sort of just
blown away
by all the aspects of course
it's not all positive
in terms of sound i think gut strings
win right the timbre is better
the feel is better however they are
really expensive that's first problem
uh another problem is they go out of
tune really quickly
uh and they don't stabilize
with synthetic strings the first you
know week or two even
uh the strings could be going flat a lot
but then they'll eventually they'll
stabilize
gut strings they're really sensitive to
humidity and you know you open a window
and the strings go
and then you turn on the ac and they go
and so they go up and down up and down
and you just have to live with more
tuning but since on a classical guitar
it's only really three strings
that are pure guts and the other ones
that are wound are much more stable
i think it's fine so so far they are
more expensive that's definitely a con
and you're going to have to do a bit
more tuning but it's not that big of a
deal the real concern i think comes in
with nails um nails chew up the gut
uh they put little indents in them and i
when i was playing with nails on fiorbo
on my gut strings i noticed that after a
few weeks
there'd be little spots where i sort of
destroyed the string
it's a bit of a mystery to me because
you know players like aguado
and lots of other 19th century
guitarists definitely played with
nails and they used gut strings so maybe
they just
they just managed so if you play with
nails i do think
gut strings still sound better but you
might have to go through strings
a little bit more often alright guys i
hope you had fun
hearing the difference between synthetic
and gut strings i had a great time and
i think i just love these strings and
i'm going to be playing a lot over the
next few days just enjoying the
the new sound of my instrument and if
you haven't yet subscribed to my channel
please do it really helps uh also if you
feel like supporting my channel if you
like my videos and want to help me make
more of them you can directly do that
by becoming a patron on patreon and if
you do so you also will receive
you know my cds mp3 downloads exclusive
guitar tips
uh and more behind the scenes content
so please check that out and i'll see
you guys next time
[Music]
later
[Music]
you